question one is begin there and this is
directly from what we looked at
yesterday so there's a language he our
language is the we need to make sure we
master because the difference between
these two is kind of small and so you
can often it you can be forgiven for
being la I'm not sure which is which and
tight remember so it's floating with it
let's do the first one like a foot part
of good one sir do you remember you
haven't even written what makes a number
at first maybe take it is they don't
actually remember it not be erected a
square or cube or a like number which
had like yeah yeah okay so when you are
when you take the square root of
something or the cube root of something
or I didn't put any other kind of roots
on there but you're searching for where
Adama came from that's what Britt mean
after all and when you get the result
it's some weird decimal garbage myths
that doesn't repeat or anything like
that just was confusing okay so for that
reason you can see here the square root
here by the price for every notice that
if you want a third blind on because 81
is a perfect square which means the
square root of just nine and that's not
only definite thing going on forever so
it's what is that this number by
contrast either served like that yeah
because if you go to your calculator i
can tell me why is the cube root of
three yeah so happy and you can see the
doesn't please just keep on going right
so that's always going to be some weird
thing because three is what a nice cubic
okay I deserve all double feature to get
that so into cert you've already dodged
these kind of cheat by the way why are
these certain one
yeah ok so the stages can be written
instructions that is true however I
suggest that actually doesn't have
anything to do with the question i'm
currently answering look back at your
definition what are like the first three
words in our definition for what the
third has to be a joke yeah there's no
square root book should refer any root
in sight at all so if this is the only
thing you're interested in you can
quickly go any of these other ones only
these who could even possibly be sir
okay and we already went that at this
one spot so therefore this is the only
one that's left now I'll come in this
pile on through in a second let me just
say right now when you have a look it
only serve on the board is this guy
that's the only one so I'm just going to
rub this off is a lot of that I'll
explain why shortly okay what maybe you
already work that one let's look at a
national nap irrational okay notice what
are you talking about irrational means
is not able to be written as a ratio
fraction importantly between two whole
numbers remember something I sort of
mentioned quickly yesterday but I didn't
emphasize so maybe if you got need to
state yesterday where we wrote down the
word irrational it's probably worth
mentioning it's not just any fractured
any ratio it's where these two numbers
are whole numbers ok that's a rational
box so if you can't do that it's
irrational okay one in four bit how
would I write that as a ratio like that
I do it cuz it's not right now how could
I be right
yeah I think we can write that as but as
a five come we yeah there you go this is
ratio it's like 95 okay we already
established that recognizes very
generatio not in turn four but some take
Bevers wants to make an issue of it I
can just make it 90 bought one and
they're both your numbers or phone if
the number is absurd which we just
already identify them you can
automatically say you can't like that
infraction so it's all so irrational
it's both of it one if you didn't
include that on your list I think you
should because it means a few different
ideas either they're related to save
both of them I'm 74 champ we're making
this book Tyler like that as a fraction
I could right ahead 0.7 ball but that
would be a decibel would I think I
wanted 74 / because in fact that's what
hurts can't leave since step is 100 like
a lot i find events what do I could
simplify the burner I suppose it doesn't
matter a whole month I can you describe
huh what is this now through your
calculator your calculator will turn
into at 1.57 blah blah blah blah okay um
it's not a parent or monitor in between
a whole number but I is not higher court
is 3.14159 26 it's not hold this is one
of this thank you if analyst yeah and I
won't attack on it was a big unsolved
back medical form for a long time people
thought well I think pi must be a a
fraction of something you just got to
find a really really big mole fraction
calculator there if you do something
like I chose feels parent in the barrio
sourcing if you type in something like
okay here's just an example just made up
I supposed to make sure it would work if
you type in this into your calculator
okay if you press equal to most of your
calculators will just hand back to you
that is that correct do you see that
just me others life okay but let's just
press the SD button turn into a decimal
and if you have a look at the decimal it
looks like it never a piece but it looks
like a mirror of you agree but the
reason it looks like that is because you
only see the first little bit if you
went far enough eventually it would
repeat and refraction does so people
fall for a long time well maybe you so
just take ages and ages and ages to
repeat so maybe we should need to
calculate a bit further and they
calculated for rental time and they
never do then one day they proved it
that actually physically can't happen
ever okay which is fancy as I descript
what we do today but that's why I this
slicer is irrational I can't write
laughs like 0.5 made up yeah it does
look because on the repeater what does
that mean any bigger number are so like
this that's another fun ok so it goes on
forever just kind of like the numbers
that are rational right the one big
difference sir we won't be a difference
what's the difference yeah because it
repeat precisely because it repeat just
like this time just like all these other
guys it actually must be a fraction each
time in and remembering quickly i'm
pretty sure in five over nine yeah is
that right yeah
ah so this is actually a fraction in
disguise the way you can recognize it is
because it repeats okay that's what
makes it a factory if you're not sure
what it is you can work out that it has
to be some color okay so fact it's
lacking okay all right let's come to a
question too well did in area first this
area 42 at a half-cent 110 meter squared
sin meter square right is that the
rentboy yes hi pontoon club a plus B
this should check out now this perimeter
is true it is true very close to being
right but didn't find a Florida
canonical and he'll be identified it was
nice windy fun okay you should the 11
squared with it now this is a question
that is deliberately crafted to see can
you look through what on the surface and
dig a little bit okay you're letting
their clearly on maybe 11 but can I use
it straight away to work out what is up
what is X is the interest actually cause
I've gotta do something before I could
work out where is something older George
my diagram any suggestion yeah so if I
put you in red line down here if I make
it so it's parallel only chance like
that again what is this hi yeah because
it's 50 years of it right so this is
fine I've got this 11 centimeters ID to
pieces this side over here is my it's
six on the left hand side which means
this leftover bit is
so far okay who's now I can go to
Pythagoras and go and work it out what
is that there is one part of put it
approximately seven point one and then
you can just make a slight adjustment so
I guess we go to 12.1 ish so I guess
this is going to be 29 I want yeah okay
so you can see on a question right this
which is repped your marks this solution
gets at least one because most of the
leg work is there right hi dad you
should there even though there's a minor
error error in it and we're going to
trim it up is there a type sort of
critical you put your working down
because I can seen it understanding just
a tiny mistake right so make sure you're
working is there 29 for one I think what
we agreed on okay